Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast für Raumfahrt und andere.
Kosmische Angelegenheiten. Und ich begrüße alle zur 116.
Sendung von Raumzeit und ja, ich befinde mich nach wie vor in der Schweiz am
CERN und das hier ist damit dann auch die sechste und letzte,
vorerst letzte Sendung zum Gesamtthema CERN.
Und nachdem ich hier zu Beginn schon die Geschichte des CERN ausgeleuchtet habe
und die Aufgabenstellung,
die sich hier die Wissenschaft stellt und wir den Beschleunigerring genauer
analysiert haben und auch schon diverse Detektoren untersucht haben,
nämlich ALICE, CMS und ATLAS, fehlt noch einer, nämlich der LHCB,
das ist jetzt das Thema und dafür begrüße ich Patrick Koppenburg.
Hallo, herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit.
Patrick, du bist Operations- und Physik-Koordinator.
Das heißt du koordinierst sowohl die Organisation als auch die Physik.
Die gehorcht sozusagen deinen Regeln, wenn ich das hier richtig interpretiere.
Das habe ich gemacht, ich war Operations Coordinator, da habe ich mich darum
gekümmert, dass die Daten vom Detektor bis zum Endbenutzer, das sind die Doktoranden meistens,
die dann die Analysen machen, dass die da richtig kommen und rechtzeitig und
dass alles gut läuft und wir auf dem Weg nichts verlieren.
Und dann wurde ich Physik-Koordinator und da setzen man Prioritäten,
welche Analysen kommen zuerst dran, welche Dissertationen von diesen Doktoranden
werden dann auch zu Publikationen vom ganzen Experiment.
Und jetzt inzwischen koordiniere ich das Analyseprogramm, also ich bin im Software.
Wir schreiben das Analyseprogramm völlig neu für den Endbenutzer,
für die letzten Daten, die wir jetzt so langsam bekommen vom LAC.
Wir haben den Detektor völlig umgebaut und dann müssen wir natürlich auch das
Software völlig umbauen.
Ok, auch über die Software können wir vielleicht mal ein bisschen ausführlicher
reden, das hatten wir bisher hier noch nicht so im Fokus.
Es würde mich natürlich erst mal interessieren, wie du überhaupt zu dem Thema
gekommen bist, wie du deinen Einstieg in die Wissenschaft gefunden hast und
letzten Endes am CERN gelandet bist.
Ich habe in Lausanne, nicht weit von hier, Physik studiert.
Andere Seite vom See sozusagen?
Ja, so ungefähr. Am Anfang war ich mehr für Astronomie interessiert und darum
habe ich mich eher in der Psyche eingestellt.
Uni eingeschrieben und nicht in der Technischen Hochschule, die auf der anderen
Seite von der Straße liegt. Denn die Astronomie war an der Uni.
Aber dann waren die Vorlesungen ziemlich langweilig von den Astronomen.
Die haben uns wahrscheinlich die falschen geschickt.
Denn zum Beispiel der Major, der Nobelpreisträger, der wäre auch einer davon
gewesen. Der hat in Genf unterrichtet.
Das ist die gleiche Gruppe. Aber die entscheiden, wer geht nach Lausanne, wer geht nach Genf.
Und irgendwann habe ich dann entdeckt, dass Teilchenphysik ganz interessant ist.
Ich wusste eigentlich als Erstjahrstudent überhaupt nichts über CERN.
Das war überhaupt kein Thema, obwohl ich 60 Kilometer von CERN entfernt gewohnt
habe. Das war überhaupt kein Thema in der Schule.
Und da lief auch nicht viel zu der Zeit.
Von welchem Zeitraum reden wir da?
Da sind wir in den 90er Jahren. Ja gut, da war Lab am, nee das war vor den 90er,
das war gerade als Lab startete.
Und irgendwie habe ich das verpasst und CERN habe ich dann entdeckt als Physikstudent.
Also ich war nicht von der Teilchenphysik angezogen, sondern von der Astronomie.
Und dann bin ich zur Teilchenphysik und da war das neue Experiment,
das neue Projekt, das wir starteten, war LACB.
Also da habe ich als Doktorand 1996 angefangen.
Das war dann zwölf Jahre bevor das Experiment überhaupt die ersten Daten bekam.
Wir waren da am optimieren und tüfteln welche Detektoren, wie wir den Detektor
bauen und simulieren, alles mögliche.
Ich war einer von den ersten Doktoranden auf diesem Experiment,
habe natürlich überhaupt keine Daten gesehen, darum bin ich dann nach meiner
Dissertation so schnell wie möglich weg, nach Japan, zum Bell Experiment,
das ähnliche Physik macht.
Und das war da am Laufen, aber dann bin ich nach zwei Jahren wieder zurück zum
CERN und seitdem bin ich hier.
Manchmal in London, manchmal in Amsterdam, aber immer mit dem LACB Experiment.
Na dann wirst du ja einiges zu berichten haben und hast die ganze Geschichte
im Prinzip mitverfolgen können von Anfang an.
Jetzt haben wir ja, das kam jetzt hier in der letzten Sendung natürlich klar
durch und ich habe es ja auch schon erwähnt,
wir sind am Zerren, wir haben hier diese Beschleunigungsringe,
diese ganze Kaskade, diese Kette von einzelnen Beschleunigern,
die sich gegenseitig die Teilchen hinein beschleunigen und jeder Ring gibt immer
wieder was dazu und der große Ring,
der LHC, der Large Hadron Collider, der hat eben diese Besonderheit,
dass er eben, also hat viele Besonderheiten, aber unter anderem halt die,
dass eben diese vier großen Detektorsysteme, die vollständig unabhängig voneinander
arbeiten da sind und während CMS und Atlas eben eine,
mehr so ein Pärchen sind, um sich gegenseitig kontrollieren zu können für so
die Hauptaufgaben, die man beim Design des LHC gesehen hat.
Alice halt sozusagen nochmal nebenan und schaut auf die Bleikerne,
die dort vorbeifliegen.
Und jetzt gibt es halt noch diesen vierten, den LHC-B, der halt so den Large
Hadron Collider nochmal so im Namen trägt, plus das kleine B.
Und was macht jetzt dieses B und warum braucht es diesen LHC-B Detektor?
Was ist das Ziel dieses Detektors?
Warum wurde der überhaupt noch mit dazu gebaut? Was will man hier herausfinden?
Also die zwei großen, Atlas und CMS, die suchen neue Teilchen.
Die wurden optimiert, dass sie den Higgs finden können. Das haben sie auch gemacht.
Jetzt suchen sie auch nach anderen Teilchen. Wir haben da ein anderes Programm.
Wir studieren CP-Verletzung. Das ist der Unterschied zwischen Materie und Antimaterie.
Und für die Leute, die das Podcast folgen, werden ja wohl wissen,
dass wir da ein Problem haben in der Kosmologie, dass wir ein Universum haben, das aus Materie ist.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das alle wissen. Erzähl mal, was das Problem ist.
Das Problem ist, wir haben ein Universum aus Materie, aus Atomen.
Und Antimaterie, das sind die gleichen, dasselbe, andersrum,
mit einer anderen elektrischen Ladung.
Und das gibt es auch, das kann man produzieren, aber man findet es in der Natur nicht.
Und dann muss man ja erklären, wie es möglich war am Anfang im Big Bang,
dass diese ganze Energie, die da war,
die sich normalerweise von den physikalischen Gesetzen in eine Hälfte in Materie
und die andere Hälfte in Antimaterie formen sollten, das dann nur Materie produziert hat. Und das geht.
Da hat Sakharov, der Friedensnobelpreisträger, aber auch Physiker,
hat erklärt, was man genau braucht. Und ein von den drei Ingredienten ist diese CP-Verletzung.
Das heißt, man braucht fundamentale Unterschiede in den physikalischen Gesetzen
zwischen Materie und Antimaterie.
Das heißt, ein Prozess, das in der Materie passiert würde, würde in der Antimaterie
leicht anders passieren.
Das gibt es, das haben wir.
Vor über 50 Jahren wurde das entdeckt. Das war ein bisschen eine Überraschung.
Dass es einen Unterschied gibt?
Dass es einen Unterschied gibt, denn zuerst dachte man, die Physik ist völlig
symmetrisch zwischen Materie und Antimaterie.
Dann wurde entdeckt, dass das nicht der Fall ist.
Die schwache Wechselwirkung sieht da Unterschiede. Aber diese Unterschiede,
die hat man gemessen und die sind viel zu klein.
Um relevant sein zu können.
Damit kann man nicht erklären, warum wir überhaupt da sind.
Aber was für Unterschiede hat man denn gefunden? Was ist denn anders?
Ja, was anders ist, das sind die Unterschiede, die wir messen.
Wir nehmen Teilchen, bei uns, wir sind am besten mit B-Mesonen,
da kommt das B her. Das sind Teilchen, wo in denen ein B-Quark ist. Es gibt sechs Quarks.
Die zwei leichtesten machen die Protonen und Neutronen, die wir alle kennen.
Und dann hat es noch vier, die schwerer sind.
Strange, Charm, Beauty und Top.
Und wir sind optimiert für das Beauty, denn das ist der Quark,
wo die CP-Verletzung am stärksten ist.
Wann wurde denn aus dem...
B Quark, was ja ursprünglich eigentlich Bottom Quark heißt und ja auch so noch dokumentiert ist.
Das Beauty, ist das jetzt sozusagen die Korrektur einer schlechten Namensgebung?
Das ist ein lustig vom soziologischen Punkt.
Wir nennen das Beauty, wir nennen uns selber LAC Beauty.
Atlas und CMS, die würden von Bottom reden.
Als die Quarks benannt wurden, gab es die zwei Möglichkeiten für das letzte
Pärchen, Top und Bottom oder Truth und Beauty.
Niemand redet von Truth. Also das T-Quark, das ist klar Top,
aber die Physiker, die das B-Quark studieren, die nennen es Beauty, die meisten.
Die, die es benutzen, um was anderes zu machen, typisch bei Atlas und CMS,
die werden es eher Bottom nennen. Also bei uns ist es eher Beauty und ich werde
wahrscheinlich Beauty sagen, aber im Grunde genommen ist es egal.
Zwei Namen für dasselbe Ding.
Also mit der Namensgebung in der Wissenschaft oder speziell in der Physik ist
es schon ein Problem. Da müsste man mal was machen.
Okay, im Zweifelsfall sagen wir einfach nur B.
Dieses Standardmodell ist ja schwierig zu verstehen. Oder generell dieser ganze Teilchen zu,
also was heißt schwierig zu verstehen, man kann sich das natürlich irgendwie
anschauen und dann hat man etwa eine Vorstellung, die ganze Mathematik nachzuvollziehen,
glaube ich entzieht sich den meisten Leuten, die jetzt nicht Physik studiert haben.
Aber ich glaube es ist generell ganz gut das halt irgendwie immer so ein bisschen
einsortieren zu können. Haben wir hier in den letzten Sendungen ja auch schon probiert.
Aber vielleicht kann man, würde ich auch gerne nochmal von dir mal so hören,
deine Meinung dieses Ding mit diesen Generationen.
Also Standardmodell haben wir ja erstmal so zwei grundsätzliche Aufspaltungen,
dass man die Leptonen, also wo die Elektronen.
Dazugehören Und Hadronen sozusagen voneinander trennt und Hadronen sind halt
die Quarks vor allem und all diese beiden Dinge gibt es halt so in so einer
dreifachen Ausführung.
Das heißt man hat festgestellt, okay es gibt Quarks und es gibt irgendwie Leptonen
und irgendwie gibt es die aber mehrfach in verschiedenen Massen.
Also dasselbe, was sich exakt genauso verhält, bloß ist es auf einmal schwerer
und zwar extrem viel schwerer und dann noch mal extrem viel schwerer.
Gibt es denn schon irgendeine Erklärung dafür, warum das so ist?
Oder wozu das gut sein soll?
Also eine Erklärung warum das so ist, das weiß ich nicht und ich glaube das weiß auch niemand.
Wir bestehen aus Up- und Downquarks und Elektronen, das ist alles die erste
Generation. Die zweite braucht man nicht.
Jede Sekunde fliegt ein Myon durch unser Körper, das ist dann die zweite Generation.
Aber das ist auch das Einzige, das wir mit der zweiten Generation zu tun haben auf diesem Planeten.
Die alles andere muss man in Beschleuniger produzieren und studieren.
Wozu das gut ist, das wissen wir,
denn es wurde 1973 von Kobayashi und Maskawa,
Die hatten da diese komische Idee, dass man im Standardmodell überhaupt CP-Verletzung
haben kann, also diesen Unterschied zwischen Quarks und Anti-Quarks,
muss es drei Generationen haben.
Am Anfang, die haben das postuliert, 1973, da kannte man drei Quarks,
war gar nicht sicher, ob das überhaupt Quarks sind oder ob das nur so ein mathematisches Modell ist.
Und das vierte Quark, Charm, also immer noch in der zweiten Generation,
das wurde dann ein Jahr später entdeckt.
Aber irgendwie wussten die schon über das Charm-Quark und haben dann gedacht,
ja kann man CP-Verletzung mit vier Quarks überhaupt machen?
Und nein, das verschwindet immer aus den Gleichungen raus.
Man muss diese dritte Generation haben und dann gibt es etwas,
was man nicht mehr rauskriegt. und.
Und dass dann die ganzen Unterschiede, die wir kennen zwischen Materie und Antimaterie,
dass diese einzige Zahl erklärt, alle unsere Messungen.
Was heißt denn jetzt CP Verletzung? Was ist denn das C und das P?
Was wird denn da verletzt? Ist das eine goldene Regel oder ein Gesetz?
Wir reden von Verletzungen jedes mal, wenn wir der Meinung sind,
dass es eine Symmetrie gibt, die universal sein sollte und dann merken wir, dass das nicht stimmt.
Eigentlich sind wir verletzt.
Das C, das ist für Charge, also alle elektrischen Ladungen werden verkehrt.
Also die Elektronen werden positiv und die Protonen werden negativ. Das ist einfach.
Das P, das ist Parität, das ist die Welt wie man sie in einem Spiegel sieht.
Und das brauchen wir, weil man wusste schon lange,
dass diese Spiegelreflexion, dass es da einen Unterschied gibt zwischen in der
schwachen Wechselwirkung,
also in den typischen Beta-Zerfällen von Atomen.
Wenn man sich so ein Beta-Zerfall anschaut und dann ein Spiegelbild,
dann kann man wissen, welches das Spiegelbild ist.
Das kann man normalerweise In der Physik nicht. Wenn ich ein Billiardspiel anschaue
und das im Spiegel ansehe, dann habe ich überhaupt keine Ahnung,
welches jetzt im Spiegel ist.
Was ist das Original?
Was ist das Original, ja.
Aber bei Antimaterie geht das?
Ja, das geht mit dem Beta-Zerfällen, also mit der Radioaktivität.
Da sieht man es gut zwischen Materie und Materie im Spiegel,
da habe ich dann einen grossen Unterschied.
Aber jetzt wird es ein Gedankenexperiment. Wenn ich jetzt ein Antiatom habe
und schaue, wie er radioaktiv zerfällt Und das schaue ich mir dann im Spiegel
an, dann kann ich das jetzt nicht mehr von einem normalen Materiezufall unterscheiden.
Das ist C und P gleichzeitig. Und das ist der Weg von Materie zu Antimaterie eigentlich.
Antimaterie sind alle Ladungen umgekehrt, aber auch rechts und links sind auch ausgetauscht.
Und das dachte man, okay, das ist ein fundamentaler Symmetrie,
der vom Universum alles respektiert, alles gut und dann wurde in den 60er Jahren
gefunden, dass das nicht der Fall ist.
Das war dann mit Zerfällen von Strange Quarks,
wo es ganz ganz kleine Unterschiede gab und das war dann eigentlich in der Geschichte
von Teilchenphysik war das so eine Sorte von Krise,
Denn es war überhaupt nicht möglich, dass man das überhaupt nicht mal parametrisieren
konnte mit den Modellen, die man damals hatte. Das geht einfach nicht.
Und dann kamen dann Kobayashi und Maskawa und haben dann einfach postuliert,
dass es dann zwei Quarks gibt, die viel zu schwer sind, um überhaupt entdeckt
zu werden und die das erklären.
Der Beautyquark wurde dann Ende 70er Jahren entdeckt und für den Topquark,
der ist so unheimlich schwer, da braucht es dann Tevatron in den 90er Jahren, um so weit zu kommen.
Das heißt entdeckt hat man nicht jetzt auf der Straße gefunden,
sondern in Beschleunigerringen entsprechend detektiert, aber nicht am CERN,
sondern in, was war das jetzt in den USA? Ja das war in den USA, ja.
Beide? Ja, beide. Es gibt so eine komische Situation, dass alle Quarks und Leptonen
in Amerika entdeckt wurden.
Und dann die Bosonen, die fanden Wechselwirkungen, Z, W und X, alle in Europa.
Vielleicht auch irgendeine Art von Verletzung, die man mal genauer untersuchen sollte.
Okay, also wenn ich das mal kurz zusammenfassen darf, wenn man sich das Standardmodell
anschaut und dann eben spezifisch dieses Problem, dass irgendwie all diese ganze
Materie und dann das ganze Standardmodell.
Wir wissen das gibt's halt auch in gespiegelter Form, das taucht aber so jetzt
in unserem Alltag nicht auf, alles was uns umgibt ist halt irgendwie Materie,
aber Antimaterie lässt sich auf jeden Fall erzeugen und sie ist auch irgendwie
im Weltall schon auch da oder nicht?
Also ist es generell einfach immer nur so ein temporäres Produkt aus Prozessen
und dann war's das auch schon wieder und es verpufft und man stellt sich jetzt
sozusagen die Frage warum verpufft es beziehungsweise warum gibt's das überhaupt?
Also man kann es produzieren. Aus reiner Energie kann ich ein Paar mit einem
Elektronen und einem Positronen produzieren. Das geht ziemlich gut.
Aber dann der Positron, der ist eigentlich stabil, könnte entlang leben.
Aber sobald er einen Elektron findet, und da gibt es ja viele davon in der Umgebung,
dann gibt es eine Annihilation und ich kriege wieder zwei Photonen raus.
Und das ist mit der ganzen Antimaterie so, dass die Schwierigkeit ist,
sie zu behalten, so lange wie möglich.
Es gibt ein Experiment am CERN, am Antimatter Decelerator,
das AD-Experiment, Die produzieren Anti-Atome,
aber da die Schwierigkeit ist, dass man die im Vakuum so lang wie möglich behalten
muss und die müssen so weit weg wie möglich von jeglicher Maclary sein, sonst sind sie weg.
Und im Universum ist das ähnlich, die werden wahrscheinlich auch produziert,
es gibt ja auch Hochenergie-Kollisionen im Universum,
aber die verschwinden wieder und das AMS-Experiment, das im Weltall ist,
Das hat auch nach Anti-Atomen gesucht und findet,
Keine oder kaum.
Das Alpha Magnet Spektrometer auf der ISS, was im Prinzip so der Beschleunigerring
ohne Ring ist. Da nimmt man einfach das, was sowieso schon beschleunigt ist
und versucht dieselben Analysen.
Okay, also das sind sozusagen die Rätsel, weil man möchte das natürlich verstehen.
Man weiß, es gibt die Antimateria, aber man weiß nicht warum und wozu und warum
es sich dann auch noch anders verhält,
noch mal besonders und dieses Beauty-Quark ist so ein bisschen der mathematische
Schlüssel, um sich das überhaupt alles mathematisch herleiten zu können,
daraus eine brauchbare Theorie abzuleiten.
Und diese Fragestellung an sich jetzt, die ist sozusagen wichtig.
Also das ist etwas, das will man einfach verstehen, weil es eben wie so viele
andere Dinge hier am CERN, ich meine es ist ja einfach mal ein Ort der Grundlagenforschung,
man will halt alles verstehen. Man kann jetzt nicht einfach so,
man könnte ja auch sagen, Antimaterie, was kümmert mich das?
Die ist ja sowieso immer gleich wieder weg.
So betrifft mich ja nicht groß. So einfach macht man es sich dann nicht,
sondern man will natürlich schauen, ist das vielleicht in gewisser Hinsicht
der Schlüssel zu noch was ganz anderem und man weiß es ja nicht.
Also baut man sich einen Detektor, um was genau zu detektieren,
diese Beauty-Quarks, das heißt auch hier konsumiert man den Teilchenstrom und
schaut spezifisch nur auf dieses eine Quark, wenn es denn in so einer Kollision entsteht.
Ja, hauptsächlich diese Quarks. Wir machen auch ein bisschen Physik mit anderen
Quarks, aber das ist das Hauptthema.
Aber warum schaut man sich dann, also man meint ja okay, das spielt jetzt sozusagen
in dieser Mathematik eine Rolle
und das heißt, man will dann genauer verstehen, was es tut, kann, macht?
Da schaut man sich die Teilchen an, in denen ein B-Quark ist.
Denn B-Quarks kann man nicht allein produzieren. Das ist ...
Das Hauptproblem, es wäre fantastisch, wenn man es direkt studieren könnte,
aber die Quarks sind immer in Pärchen oder in Dreiergruppen wie Protonen und
Neutronen, also schauen wir uns die Teilchen an, in denen es einen B-Quark hat
und dann noch ein anderer Quark.
Und diese B-Quarks, die leben ziemlich kurz, so ein Millionstel von Millionstel
Sekunden, wir sind in 10 Tau hoch, minus zwölf.
Und dann zerfallen sie und wir schauen uns an, wie sie zerfallen.
Und spezifisch schauen wir uns an, ob die B-Quarks und die Anti-B-Quarks ähnlich zerfallen.
Und ähnlich oft. Und das ist eigentlich der Schlüssel, um herauszufinden,
wie viel CP Verletzung es hat in den Experimenten, die wir machen.
Eine ganz große Liste von Zerfallsmöglichkeiten, die wir uns anschauen.
Und dann messen wir den Unterschied zwischen Bequarks und Anti-Bequarks und
versuchen zu verstehen, woher diese Unterschiede kommen und besonders,
ob die mit der Vorhersage vom Standardmodell passen oder nicht.
Und bis jetzt passen sie.
Das ist natürlich nicht das, was ich gehofft habe.
Aber es passt ganz gut. Das heißt, dass diese einzige Zahl von Kobayashi und
Maskawa das alles erklärt und das heißt, das Problem haben wir immer noch mit
der Antimaterie vom Universum.
Was wir gehofft hatten ist, dass wir dann irgendwelche Unterschiede sehen und
dass es dann kleine Unterschiede zwischen der Vorhersage und der Messung gibt,
die dann mit anderen Parametern und anderer Physik erklärt werden müssen.
So wie muss man denn dem ganzen technisch auf den Pelz rücken?
Also wenn man jetzt, also ich meine man muss ja jetzt erstmal eine Kollision
beobachten bei dem jetzt diese Beauty Quarks entstehen.
Das tun sie wahrscheinlich mit einer bestimmten Wahrscheinlichkeit,
die vielleicht nicht so hoch ist, aber ausreichend, damit man halt auch nie was sieht.
Ähnelt jetzt sozusagen dieser Detektor den anderen oder muss man hier aus irgendwelchen
Gründen ganz anders herangehen?
Ja wir gehen ganz anders heran. Aus mehreren Gründen, aber der Hauptgrund ist,
dass der B-Quark ziemlich leicht ist.
Wir reden da von 5 GeV, das ist fünfmal eine Protonenmasse.
Der Higgs ist auf 125 und das ist ein großer Unterschied in so einer Kollision von Protonen,
wenn man ein schweres Teilchen produziert, dann kann es überall hingehen,
in alle möglichen Richtungen.
Die leichten Teilchen, die werden meistens bleiben sie in der Nähe von dem Strahlen
und gehen dann seltener zur Decke hoch.
Und da ist es dann interessanter, dass wir uns nur die Gegend anschauen,
die um den LHC Strahl ist.
Also wir haben da einen Detektor, das sieht mehr wie eine Pyramide aus,
eine ziemlich steile Pyramide, horizontale.
Und wir schauen uns an, was nach vorne geht. Wir könnten uns auch anschauen,
was nach hinten geht, in die andere Richtung.
Aber dafür haben wir einfach nicht genug Platz.
Also wir haben entschieden, gut, die Hälfte der Daten, alles was in die falsche
Richtung geht, das ist verloren.
Wir schauen uns ganz genau an, was in die Richtung von Atlas eigentlich,
dass alles was auf diese Seite geht, dass wir uns das ganz genau anschauen.
Das hat einen anderen Vorteil, dass wir da in dieser Richtung schauen,
ist dass wir müssen diese Bequaks identifizieren und der Schlüssel ist,
dass sie eine Lebensdauer haben, die sehr kurz ist, aber nicht null.
Und das können wir auflösen.
Wenn sie ganz ganz schnell sind, wenn sie noch hohen Momentum haben,
dann fliegen die so ungefähr einen Zentimeter.
Das ist so die Größenordnung, die wir haben. Und das können wir mit unserem Detektor auflösen.
Das ist für Atlas und CMS, die versuchen auch diese Physik zu machen,
das ist nicht deren Hauptthema, aber die haben auch Gruppen,
die das machen, ist das schwieriger, weil die haben ja ihre Detektoren,
die weiter weg sind von Prognosen.
Wir können ganz ganz nah ran.
Also wie groß muss man sich den ganzen Aufbau so vorstellen?
Vielleicht können wir uns mal von den Dimensionen ein bisschen annähern.
Ja, also das Experiment ist so ungefähr 20 Meter lang und wir sind da in einer
großen Höhle und durch die Höhle geht der LAC Strahl.
Aber der Kollisionspunkt ist auf der Seite von der Höhle. Also eigentlich gerade da, wo sie endet.
Und dann eine Seite, wie gesagt, da geht es dann in die Mauer oder in den Tunnel vom LAC.
Und die andere Seite geht dann in unsere LACB-Höhle rein. Und da haben wir einen
Detektor, der ist 20 Meter lang und am anderen Ende dann so bis zu 10 Meter hoch.
Um den Kollisionspunkt haben wir einen Vertex-Detektor. Das ist ein Detektor,
in dem wir die Zerfallspunkte, das ist dieser Vertex, so genau wie möglich auflösen wollen.
Zuerst an den Primär, den Kollisionspunkt von den zwei Protonen.
Und dann fliegt dieses B-Quark ein Zentimeter oder so, zerfällt in andere Teilchen
und diese anderen Teilchen werden dann entdeckt.
Und dann können wir uns ausrechnen, wo genau dieser Zerfall war.
Das heißt, der Detektor detektiert jetzt das B-Quark selbst eigentlich nicht unmittelbar,
sondern man schaut einfach nur auf
die Zerfallsprodukte, die eben diese Selbstauslöschung quasi hervorbringt.
Das ist ja hier immer ein wiederkehrendes Thema, dass einfach bestimmte Teilchen
sind dann einfach nicht stabil oder zumindest nicht besonders lange und dann
teilen sie sich eben in andere Teilchen auf,
aber das ist so ein spezifischer Fingerabdruck, den man dann einfach sofort
erkennen kann, dass man sagt, okay alles klar, das war mal wieder eins.
Wobei es könnte ja auch sein, dass mal eins kommt, was sich irgendwie in andere
Bestandteile aufteilt oder ist das nicht?
Ja, die möglichen Zerfälle von Beegwarks sind unendlich lang.
Da hat man eine ganze Liste, Seiten und Seiten von möglichen Zerfällen und wir
interessieren uns eigentlich auch für die seltensten,
die man in einem von einer Million oder sogar seltener Beegwarks hat.
So exotisches Zeug.
Ja exotisches Zeug. Aber das wird dann später gemacht,
dann schauen wir uns die Falzprodukte an und versuchen sie zu kombinieren und
wenn das ein BMW-Sohn ergibt, dann haben wir einen Kandidaten und wenn nicht,
dann schmeißen wir ihn weg.
Das heißt der ganze technische Aufbau ist jetzt nicht so brutal groß wie das
jetzt bei CMS oder Atlas ist. Kennt man ja alle die Bilder. Irgendwie riesiger
Ring mitten in der Erde, irgendwie 20 Meter hoch.
Hier gibt es auch 20 Meter, aber es geht mehr so in die Länge.
Und was war das? 10 Meter hoch?
Diese Pyramidenstruktur, also dass man sozusagen so einen Schusskanal,
der sich da ergibt, so einen Verteilungskanal noch abgedeckt bekommt.
Und ist dann aber die Detektortechnik jetzt selber, die diese Teilchen registriert,
ist die dann wiederum vergleichbar mit dem, was in den anderen Detektoren gemacht
wird? Kommen auch diese Siliziumfolien und so weiter zum Einsatz?
Das ist sehr ähnlich, denn das ist von der Physik definiert.
Wir müssen diese Teilchen finden, wir müssen ihr Momentum messen,
das heißt wir brauchen ein magnetisches Feld Und dann brauchen wir Detektoren
da drin, die die Spuren, die sie hinterlassen, messen.
Und dann gibt es eine Serie von Detektoren, die dann teils spezifisch sind.
Zuerst der elektromagnetische Kalorimeter, das ist für Elektronen und Photonen.
Und nachdem hat es dann keine Elektronen und Photonen mehr, denn die haben sich da drin aufgelöst.
Und dann kommen dann die Hadronen, Kaon und Pion, das sind die leichten Teilchen
mit Quarks, mit leichten Quarks. Und dann am Ende haben wir die Myonen.
Und diese Reihenfolge ist in allen Detektoren dieselbe.
Da wo wir einen kleinen Unterschied haben, ist unser magnetisches Feld ziemlich
einfach. Wir haben einen Dipol, also das ist alles was eine elektrische Ladung
hat, geht links und die andere Ladung geht rechts.
Und dann ab und zu, jeden Monat oder so, wechseln wir das magnetische Feld und dann wird es umgekehrt.
Und dann haben wir noch Cherenkov Detektoren, mit denen wir die Teilchen gut unterscheiden können.
Denn da messen wir eigentlich deren Masse. Also da können wir Pionen und Kaonen
und von Protonen unterscheiden. Die.
Die sind für die meisten Detektoren, ATLAS und CMS, die sehen absolut identisch aus.
Bei uns können wir die unterscheiden, indem wir einen Detektoren haben mit einem
Gas, mit einem schweren Gas.
Und da fliegen diese Teilchen schneller als die Lichtgeschwindigkeit,
nicht die Lichtgeschwindigkeit im Vakuum, Lichtgeschwindigkeit im Gas und das
gibt dann so etwas ähnliches wie die Überschallgeschwindigkeit von einem Flugzeug,
dass es dann ein Bumm gibt, ein Quantenbumm und das gibt dann Licht und dieses
Licht messen wir und je nachdem in welche Richtung das Licht geht,
wissen wir dann wie schnell das Teilchen war und von der Geschwindigkeit können
wir dann die Masse ausrechnen.
Das ist diese Tcherenkow Strahlung, was man ja auch in der Atmosphäre beobachten kann.
Tcherenkow Teleskope nutzen ja genau diesen Effekt aus und schauen sich sozusagen
an, ob es irgendwo mal kurz blau blitzt und wenn man dann gut genug hingeschaut
hat, dann weiß man Bescheid. Ja genau.
Okay.
Das heißt das ist so in der Kaskade dann sozusagen hinten angestellt nochmal.
Wir haben zwei davon, einen am Anfang und einen anderen am Ende,
auf jeder Seite vom Magneten. Das hat damit zu tun, dass wenn wir nur einen
bauen würden, müsste er viel zu groß sein.
Die inneren Teilchen werden am Ende entdeckt und die, die ein bisschen weiter
vom LHC Strahl sind, die kommen am Anfang an.
Okay das heißt, das ist sozusagen das Setup und ich würde mal sagen von der Detektorkomplexität,
der technischen her ist es überschaubar, weil man eigentlich so Standardtechnik,
sag ich mal salopp, Also was halt in den anderen auch installiert ist,
ohne gleich so einen großen Popanz zu machen mit irgendwie Riesenmagneten und
so weiter, sondern man schaut halt nur in eine Richtung und man ist halt eben
auch sehr spezifisch auf dieses eine Teilchen fixiert bzw.
Dann eben auf die Detektion der entsprechenden Ergebnisteilchen,
ich weiß gar nicht wie man das nennt, also das Resultat der Auflösung dieses
Teilchens sich darauf konzentriert.
So und jetzt habt ihr natürlich dasselbe Problem wie alle anderen.
Da fallen eine ganze Menge Daten an.
Und jetzt muss man ja gucken was ist davon relevant und was ist nicht relevant.
Welche Mengen an Kollisionen wird letzten Endes beobachtet?
Also jetzt, wir hatten gerade ein Upgrade, um da die Datenmenge zu vergrößern.
Da mussten wir einige Detektorteile ändern, denn die konnten da nicht mithalten.
Und jetzt schreiben wir so ungefähr 10 Kilohertz, also 10.000 Kollisionen pro
Sekunde von den ursprünglich 30 Millionen.
Also das ist noch immerhin ein großer Faktor, den wir rausschmeißen.
Aber das ist viel besser als das was wir vorher hatten. Da waren wir so auf
1000 bis 2000 Kollisionen.
Aber das bedeutet auch, dass wir kommen so langsam an die Grenze der Physik.
Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt weniger
schreiben würden oder wenn wir die Kollisionsrate raufschrauben würden,
Dann würden wir Signal rausschmeißen.
Wir sind am Limit. Das heißt, was dann aus dem Detektor rausgeschrieben wird,
das wird dann auch analysiert.
Früher am Anfang, als wir kleinere Kollisionsraten hatten,
da konnten wir noch ziemlich salopp entscheiden was wir behalten und was nicht
und dann offline uns genau die Sachen anschauen und dann entscheiden was dann
in die Endalyse geht und was nicht.
Diesen Luxus haben wir jetzt nicht mehr. Jetzt müssen wir sofort entscheiden
und das heißt innerhalb von Sekunden müssen wir entscheiden was wir schreiben und was nicht.
Innerhalb von Sekunden oder innerhalb von Bruchteilen von Sekunden?
Ja, das weder noch eigentlich. Wir haben da eine große Computerform,
gerade neben dem Detektor und die machen die ganzen Berechnungen,
um eben die Masse und die Position von diesen B-Zerfällen zu finden und aufgrund
dieser Information wird dann entschieden.
Das muss schnell passieren, denn sonst sammeln sich die Daten an und dann gibt es einen Stau.
Wir haben aber auch Harddisks.
Wir speichern die Daten. Wir machen eine erste einfache Selektion,
dann speichern wir die Daten.
Es kann nur ein paar Minuten sein, es kann aber auch bis zu einer Woche gehen
und während dieser Zeit machen wir dann die volle Kalibration vom Detektor,
da schauen wir uns andere Prozesse an, von denen wir genau wissen,
was wir erwarten sollen.
Wenn sich ein Detektor verschoben hat,
dann kann man das in der Software korrigieren. Man muss es aber wissen.
Zuerst lauft man das und dann kommt die zweite Stufe und da wird wirklich die Endanalyse gemacht.
Also die Endselektion und am Ende wird dann rausgeschrieben.
Diese Idee, dass wir Harddisks benutzen und dass wir die Daten zwischenspeichern,
das war noch eine komische Geschichte, denn ursprünglich haben wir ja einfach
CPUs gekauft, wir wollten so viel wie möglich Rechenkraft.
Und wenn man das bestellt bei den großen Computerfirmen, dann kommt immer ein
Harddisk mit, obwohl wir die gar nicht brauchen. Das ist ja nicht ein echter
Computer, wo wir etwas speichern müssen.
Und die rausschrauben, das wäre eine riesengroße Arbeit gewesen.
Also haben wir einfach drin gelassen und irgendwann kam dann die Idee,
warum brauchen wir die nicht?
Könnten wir sie nicht brauchen, um irgendwelche Daten dazwischen zu speichern,
damit wir dann auch diese Selektion
laufen lassen, während überhaupt keine Kollisionen passieren im LAC.
Der LAC läuft so 10-20% der Zeit und während dem Rest der Zeit passiert nicht viel.
Und da kann man diese Computer aber immer noch brauchen. Und damit maximieren
wir eigentlich die Effizienz von unseren Computern und schreiben so viel Daten wie möglich raus.
Im Endeffekt was definiert, wie viel wir rausschreiben, ist was wir dann offline
in den Zentren von den Universitäten speichern können.
Nur um sich das mal vorstellen zu können, wie groß ist so die Datenmenge einer
einzelnen Kollision, die man jetzt aufzeichnet?
Was wir aufzeigen sind so ungefähr 100 Kilobyte.
100 Kilobyte pro Minute.
Das ist wenn man die ganze Kollision aufzeichnet. Was wir manchmal machen und
eigentlich jetzt inzwischen auch meistens machen ist, dass wir nur die Teilchen
rausschreiben, die uns wirklich interessieren.
Das heißt, die B-Quarks und C- und C-Fall-Produkte.
In so einer typischen Kollision, die Bequarks werden immer in Pärchen produziert,
da hat es immer ein Bequark und ein Anti-Bequark.
Normalerweise finden wir nur einen von beiden, manchmal haben wir Glück und finden beide.
Und dann hat es noch ungefähr 100 leichte Teilchen, so Pionen,
Karonen, Protonen, Neutronen, die wir überhaupt nicht sehen und so weiter.
Und die interessieren uns ziemlich wenig und die können wir dann eigentlich
schon am Anfang rausschmeißen.
Das heißt man ist bei 10 KB und nicht bei 100.
Ja und dann sind wir nicht mehr bei 100 KB aber bei weniger als 10 KB.
Aber das muss man dann immer noch mal 10.000 machen und das ist eine Sekunde
und so weiter. Am Ende ist man schnell in den Petabytes.
Ja das ist ja generell eine Herausforderung das zu machen.
Aber diese Entscheidung, was man jetzt nimmt und was man nicht nimmt,
die muss ja dann auch irgendwie gefällt werden und die muss ja dann vor allem
auch extrem schnell gefällt werden, wenn man jetzt 10.000,
Messungen hat pro Ding, das heißt ja nicht nur 10.000 Kollisionen passieren,
sondern nur bei 10.000 entscheidet man sich dafür sie zu speichern.
Da sind ja noch ein paar. Wie viele Kollisionen schmeißt man weg und speichert sie nicht?
Ja das sind ungefähr 30 Millionen pro Sekunde.
Also der Großteil wird weg?
Die meisten davon haben überhaupt keine B-Quarks drin.
Also die kann man ziemlich einfach rausschmeißen und bei den anderen,
da hat es dann immer noch B-Quarks, die da waren aber nicht gut genug aufgelöst
wurden oder die einen Zerfall haben, die uns nicht interessiert oder irgendetwas.
Insofern haben wir das Glück, dass wir genau wissen, was wir messen wollen.
Und dann haben wir unsere Liste von Zerfallen, die wir speichern wollen und
dann machen wir eine Messung.
Das ist nicht so, als würden wir jetzt ein Teilchen suchen und eventuell finden
wir es nicht, weil es dann systematisch rausgeschmissen wurde.
Wir wissen, was wir messen und wir wissen, welche Zerfälle wir behalten wollen
und dann messen wir einfach, wie viel davon wir hatten. und besonders wie viel
von Bequax und wie viel von Anti-Bequax.
So, das heißt jetzt sammelt man so diese ganzen Daten und dann schaut man sich
das danach an und das war es dann eigentlich auch schon.
Also ist da noch mehr Magie am Start oder ist das dann quasi schon das Endergebnis?
Wie viel nimmt dann die Analyse dieser Daten ein?
Ja dann die Analyse selber, da haben wir dann eine große Menge Analysegruppen.
Wir sind ja ungefähr 1000 Physiker am Experiment.
Und darunter haben wir eine ziemlich große Analysegruppe.
Für uns ist groß vielleicht so 20, 30 Leute, die an einer wichtigen Analyse
arbeiten. Und wir haben auch kleine Gruppe, da sind typischerweise ein Doktorand
und sein Professor oder Postdoc.
Aber diese Analysen, die dauern dann auch oft ziemlich lang, jahrelang.
Die Messung kann man ziemlich schnell machen, aber dann zum genau wissen,
wie genau die Messung war und ob man alles verstanden hat, ob man alle Untergründe
verstanden hat, das dauert dann eine gewisse Zeit.
Und wir haben bis jetzt noch keine Analyse mit den neuesten Daten, die rauskommt.
Die meisten Analysen, die wir haben, die Publikationen, die wir machen,
das waren Daten bis 2018, denn 19, 20 bis 22 hatte der Detektor überhaupt,
hatte der LEC eine Pause.
Und aber wir haben immer noch auch Analysen, die Daten benutzen von 2011 und
12 und die sich die 2015 bis 18 Daten noch überhaupt nicht angeschaut haben.
Sie haben die erste Analyse noch nicht fertig.
Normalerweise macht man die in der Reihenfolge. Manchmal auch in der verkehrten Reihenfolge.
Ok, man geht ein bisschen hinterher.
Das sind halt Präzisionsmessungen und wenn man da ganz kleine Effekte messen will,
dann muss man da ganz genau hinschauen und ganz sicher sein,
dass es nicht irgendwie so ein Parasit hat, Das ist etwas, an das man nicht
gedacht hatte, das dann so aussieht wie sein Signal und das halt nicht Signal ist.
Das ist überall in der Wissenschaft so und bei uns natürlich auch ein Problem,
dass wir dann alles ganz genau verstehen müssen.
So jetzt ist ja sozusagen das ausgerufene Ziel ist so CP Verletzungen in irgendeiner
Form festzustellen und rauszufinden ob denn irgendwas ist.
Aber jetzt hast du ja gesagt alles was bisher beobachtet wurde passt zu dem
Standardmodell bisher.
Was genau müsste denn da passieren, um hier einen Ansatz zu finden für diese Erklärung?
Was in diesem ganzen Kollisions-Dekonstruktions-Modell müsste dann anders sein?
Wir messen mit immer größerer Genauigkeit diese CP-Verletzung.
Wir hoffen immer, dass wenn unsere Genauigkeit besser wird, dass wir dann kleine
Unterschiede finden, die bis jetzt noch nicht aufzulösen sind.
Diese CP-Verletzung, die kommt ja alles von der schwachen Wechselwirkung.
Also das ist ein Quark und aus diesem Quark kommt ein anderes Quark und dann ein W-Boson.
Das ist der Vektor von der schwachen Wechselwirkung, das dann irgendwie zerfällt
und in entweder Lepton oder dann andere Quarks.
Was möglich wäre, ist, dass es andere Teilchen gibt, die da in diesem Spiel
auch mitmachen, die noch nicht entdeckt wurden.
Eigentlich ein Weboson ist ein Faktor 20 schwerer als ein Bequark.
Das ist überhaupt nur möglich dank Heisenberg und der Quantenmechanik,
dass die überhaupt da mitspielen.
Die entstehen für eine ganz kurze Zeit und dann verschwinden sie sofort wieder.
Im Endeffekt wurde Energie behalten, aber im kürzeren Moment wird etwas produziert,
das eigentlich schwerer ist als ein Bigfrog.
Und da könnten wir auch noch viel schwerere Teilchen produzieren,
die da mitspielen, die eventuell zu schwer sind für den LHC,
dass sie in den direkten Kollisionen gar nicht gefunden werden könnten.
Von Atlas und CMS. Und die würden dann unsere Messungen leicht ändern und je
genauer wir messen, desto schwerere Teilchen, können wir empfindlich sein für schwerere Teilchen.
Je genauer wir werden, desto höher gehen wir in der Massenskala.
Was ist denn jetzt so gefunden worden bisher? Also ich meine man hat vielleicht
nicht unbedingt jetzt alles das gefunden,
was man gerne finden möchte, aber so ist es halt nun mal mit der Wissenschaft,
man kriegt das nicht alles immer so serviert, wie es bestellt wurde,
aber trotz alledem dürfte ja aus den Daten auch schon eine ganze Menge Erkenntnissaft
gemolken werden können.
Was hat dieser Detektor alles herausfinden können bisher? Worauf weist du es hin?
Ja, wir haben sehr viele Zerfälle entdeckt, die noch gar nicht bekannt waren,
die dann mit mehr Daten dann auch wieder neue Studienobjekte werden.
Am Anfang sieht man nur zwei oder drei und dann kann man sich ausrechnen,
ja, in zehn Jahren habe ich dann genug, um eine neue Messung zu machen.
Wir haben auch neue Teilchen entdeckt. Das sind Teilchen aus Quarks,
also nicht fundamentale Teilchen.
Besonders waren wir da groß in der Presse wegen der Entdeckung von Pentaquarks und Tetraquarks.
Das ist eigentlich etwas, das wir gar nicht wirklich auf dem wissenschaftlichen Programm hatten.
Das kam nur aus den Daten raus.
Aus übrigens einer dieser CP Verletzungen Analyse. Da haben wir uns die Daten genau hingeschaut,
nicht verstanden was da passiert in diesen Daten und da war dann ein Untergrund,
da war dann dieser Pentaquark und diesen Zerfall konnten wir nur modellieren
indem wir einen Pentaquark einbezogen haben.
Penta S5?
Trenta S5, das sind Objekte mit vier Quarks und einem Antiquark.
Und wir haben auch Tetraquarks mit zwei Quarks und zwei Antiquarks.
Irgendwann werden wir vielleicht Gruppen von sechs finden.
Da hätten wir dann zwei Möglichkeiten, entweder drei und drei oder sechs Quark
in einem Päckchen oder sechs Antiquarks.
Das sind die Möglichkeiten, die es gibt. Was uns das sagt, das ist keine neue
Physik, das ist, das erklärt uns wie die starke Wechselwirkung,
die QCD, Quantenchromodynamik, wie das funktioniert.
Und das ist das schwierige Thema in dieser ganzen Forschung,
weil man da sehr schwierig, sehr schlecht Vorhersagen machen kann.
Also ich hab bisher das so verstanden, dass die Quarks eigentlich und deswegen
ja auch diese Analogie mit der Farbe so in Dreierpärchen daher kommen.
Und weil man eben drei hat und man Wissenschaft ja immer nach einfachen Analogien aussicht halten,
dann sozusagen den Vergleich mit der Lichtmischung gemacht hat und dann eben
sozusagen das Wort Farbe benutzt, um hier etwas auszudrücken,
dass man hier so ein Ternäresystem hat eigentlich.
Also was sozusagen aus drei Komponenten besteht.
In dem Fall halt sozusagen diese Analogie zu rot, grün, blau,
auch wenn es mit Farbe alles nichts zu tun hat.
Und das ist sozusagen das Wirken dieser Quarks,
die kombinieren sich halt und das klassische Beispiel ist halt die Protonen
und die Neutronen in jedem Atomkern, die sich eben aus je drei Quarks, aber dann halt eben...
Der eine und der andere Variante, also Up- und Down-Quark, sozusagen zusammensetzen.
Und jetzt kommen Penta-Quarks um die Ecke und Tetra-Quarks und sagen so,
ja nö, geht aber auch anders. Wie passt das jetzt zusammen?
Ja das passt zusammen. Wir haben auch Mesonen, das sind Gruppen von zwei mit
immer einem Quark und einem Anti-Quark.
Also da ist zum Beispiel Grün und Anti-Grün.
Im Endeffekt will man immer farbneutral sein. Warbige Objekte gibt es nicht in der Natur.
Ich kann Meson haben, Quark-Antiquark mit Grün und Antigrün, Resultat Null.
Ich kann Proton haben mit Rot-Grün-Blau, Resultat ist Weiß, das geht auch.
Und dann kann ich einen Tetraquark haben, das sind dann zwei Pärchen,
also Grün-Antigrün und Rot-Antirot zum Beispiel, das geht auch.
Und die Pentaquarks, die wären dann wie ein Proton und ein Meson zusammen,
also grün, antigrün und dann noch grün, blau, rot und das gibt dann auch wieder weiß.
Anti heißt doch jetzt Antimateria.
Ja, ich habe da Antiquarks drin.
Aber ich dachte die sind immer gleich wieder weg, wenn sie da sind.
Die zerfallen sehr schnell.
Also sozusagen sehr vorübergehende Zustände, die jetzt im Rahmen dieser Kollision
stattfinden. Es ist nicht so, dass jetzt auf einmal Fünfergruppen durch das
Standardmodell marodieren und alles durcheinander bringen?
Nein, nein, nein. Also diese exotische Hadronen, wie man sie nennt,
das sind, die leben ganz, ganz kurze Zeiten, so 10 hoch minus 23 Sekunden.
Ich glaube, wir haben einen gefunden, der lebt zu 10 hoch minus 21.
Das war dann schon Weltrekord.
In der Lebensdauer, in der langen Lebensdauer. Die verschwinden sofort.
Diese zwei Quarks und Antiquarks, die drehen umeinander rum und irgendwann sehen
sie, da ist da ja jemand und dann pups, dann gibt es eine Annihilation und die
zerfallen in irgendetwas leichteres.
Was kann denn jetzt sozusagen der Beitrag sein aus diesen Messungen,
die meine LACB nimmt so für das weitere Verständnis der Physik und in welche
der Theoriewelten, die gerade so verfolgt werden, reicht das alles noch mit rein?
Ist aus meiner Position auch ein bisschen schwer nachzuvollziehen.
Wahrscheinlich generell ein bisschen schwer nachzuvollziehen,
aber ich hab auf jeden Fall mit zu kauen.
Also wir haben da, da müssen wir vielleicht mehrere Themen diskutieren.
Zuerst mal die ganze Themengruppe über QCD.
Alle diese Teilchen, die wir entdecken mit den Pentaquarks und Tetraquarks,
aber es gibt auch Barion, also Dreierquarks,
die wir entdeckt haben, Die erzählen uns etwas über QCD,
über wie Quarks sich zusammenformen und welche Gruppen von Quarks überhaupt
möglich sind, von der Natur aus erlaubt sind, auch wenn nur für sehr kurze Zeit und welche nicht.
Und da wir mit QCD keine Vorhersagen machen können, weil alle Rechnungen sind
hoffnungslos, Also QCD, Quanten Chromodynamik, also dieses Farbenmodell von
dem wir gerade gesprochen haben.
Ja, dieses Farbenmodell mit dem kann man sehr schnell sehr schwierig Vorhersagen machen.
Brauchen wir Daten die dieses Modell verbessern, man kann nicht von den Grundprinzipien,
vom Standardmodell, Von den Gleichungen kann man nichts ausrechnen,
aber man kann das modellisieren, was...
Aufgrund von Messungen, die gemacht wurden. Je mehr Messungen wir machen,
desto besser versteht man das.
Es gibt auch dann verschiedene Techniken, diese Berechnungen zu machen,
die man dann auch darauf eichen kann und bessere Vorhersagen machen.
Und das ist wichtig, um die CP-Verletzung zu verstehen und um seltene Zerfälle,
da komme ich dann noch drauf, zu verstehen.
Aber auch für Forschungen von Atlas und CMS und Alice.
Wir haben alle das Problem, wir haben Protonen, die eine Kollision machen. Das sind Quarks.
Da hat es diese Farben und diese Gluonen, die zusammenbinden.
Und da muss man dann immer genau verstehen, was, wenn wir etwas messen,
was ist ja jetzt die Physik, die uns interessiert?
Und was ist eigentlich nur das dreckige QCD, das man nicht richtig verstehen
kann und das eigentlich ziemlich uninteressant ist, weil es sehr auf sehr tiefe Energien ist.
Da hat es immer diese Suppe mit leichten Quarks und leichten Gluonen,
die man berücksichtigen muss, aber die man nicht wirklich beschreiben kann mathematisch.
Und daher machen wir auch Messungen in dem Sektor, um das besser zu modellieren.
Dann haben wir noch ein großes Programm, um eben diese neue Teilchen,
neue Physik zu finden, die eventuell von den anderen Experimenten nicht sichtbar
ist, weil es einfach zu hoch in Energie ist, in Masse.
Und die über Quanteneffekten in den Zerfällen von den B-Mesonen auftauchen.
Und bis jetzt hatten wir...
Regelmäßig haben wir da einige Messungen, wo man dann Augen öffnet,
oh da ist etwas, da könnte etwas sein und dann messen wir genauer und dann verschwindet es wieder.
Also bis jetzt haben wir nichts, wo wir klar sagen können, oh da ist neue Physik.
Aber wir gehen immer näher dran und wir sind aber noch ziemlich weit von der
Auflösung, von der ultimativen Auslösung vom Detektor und auch vom Standardmodell.
Wir können noch weiter vermessen und wir haben noch gute Möglichkeiten,
Abweichungen zu messen zwischen dem Standardmodell und den anderen Modellen,
die irgendwelche Teilchen vorhersagen, die dann erklären könnten,
warum das Universum so ist, wie es ist.
Was wir wissen ist, dass das Standardmodell falsch ist. Wir wissen nur nicht wo und wie genau.
Warum wissen wir das? Was ist falsch?
Was falsch ist, also der Hauptgrund für mich ist die Kosmologie. Da passt etwas nicht.
Die CP-Verletzung ist nicht groß genug, einige Leute werden dunkle Materie sagen,
aber da kann man nicht ultimativ beweisen, dass das etwas mit dem Standardmodell
zu tun hat, dass das wirklich Teilchen sind.
Es könnten ja auch kleine schwarze Löcher sein oder sowas. Das ist auch nicht
völlig ausgeschlossen.
Das wird oft gesagt, aber tatsächlich, wenn es ein Teilchen ist,
dunkle Materie, dann ist es im Schwandartmodell nicht drin. Da brauchen wir
auch einen neuen Sektor.
Also es ist nicht vielleicht zwangsläufig falsch, es ist nur nicht vollständig.
Genau, ja. Wir sehen das immer als eine Approximation, die sehr gut funktioniert
für die Energien, die wir als Menschen produzieren können und studieren können.
Wenn man denn unendlich hoch geht, dann weiss man, dass es irgendwann mal zusammenfällt.
Aber so weit sind wir noch nicht gekommen.
Und das ist das ähnlich wie die Gravitation von Newton, das passt ganz gut.
Für alles was wir Menschen machen geht es ganz gut. Und das ist das nur wenn
man so langsam GPS Satelliten um die Erde schießt, dass man merkt,
ah ja jetzt brauche ich generelle Relativität, da funktioniert Newton nicht mehr.
Oder halt Planetenumlaufplanen.
Genau so, Präzession von Merkur und so weiter.
Das sind diese kleinen Effekte, die wir eben suchen zum Beweisen, dass da ist was.
Ich finde das faszinierend, weil das ist jetzt alles sehr komplexe Geschichte
so mit all diesen ganzen Teilchen und wie sie interagieren und diese zahlreichen
Ebenen und was kann in was verteilt werden.
Aber im Prinzip, wenn man einen Strich drunter zieht, ist es halt so,
diese ganze Detektion, diese ganze permanente Beobachten, höher auflösen,
genauer hinschauen, Relevanz erkennen und die dann eben speichern,
um sie später analysieren zu können.
Also das, was der LHCb-Detektor macht, was die anderen Detektoren natürlich
im Prinzip genauso machen,
das ist alles so eine permanente Unterfütterung der allgemeinen Forschung und
auch der Unterstützung oder eben auch vielleicht der Auslöschung bestimmter Theorien,
die halt so im Raum stehen, die ja alle irgendwie so ein bisschen Kandidat zu sein scheinen für okay,
wir fixen jetzt das Standardmodell, wir erklären halt auch noch das,
was bisher nicht erklärt wurde und da ist die Antimaterie sozusagen so ein Baustein,
der irgendwie noch nicht so richtig erklärt ist.
Die dunkle Materie ist so dieses, ja Loch hätte ich jetzt fast gesagt,
also sozusagen dieser Bereich, der nicht genug Daten liefert,
warum man sich denn so verhält, wie er sich verhält mit der Gravitation.
Nicht zu reden von der dunklen Energie, die unser Universum expandiert,
auch dafür gibt es keine Erklärung. Plus dann eben diese ganzen Brücken,
die derzeit versucht werden zu bauen mit Supersymmetrie und sozusagen.
Generell natürlich dieser großen Frage,
ja, so das eine Modell, was irgendwie alles erklärt, wo dann am besten auch
noch Gravitation mit dabei ist und dann hoffe ich, es ist auch Teleportation
dabei, dass man das auch mal erledigt.
Magst du noch zum Abschluss irgendwas hinzufügen, was du dir so wünschst oder wo du drauf setzt?
Ich meine bisher habt ihr vielleicht nicht unbedingt das gefunden,
was ihr finden wolltet, aber andere Sachen gefunden. Was ist so das Potential
in dem Projekt, wo ihr noch drauf hofft?
Ja, wir sind jetzt in der Phase, wir haben einen neuen Detektor aufgebaut.
Effektiv ist dieses Upgrade war ein riesiges Projekt.
Unser Detektor ist jetzt alles installiert. Jetzt müssen wir noch die ganzen
neuen Detektoren verstehen und das ist natürlich auch sehr spannend jetzt,
dass wir wir sind in einer Phase, wo wir von der Phase 1 vom Experiment zur
Phase 2 gehen, die eigentlich ursprünglich nicht vorgesehen war.
Und in der wir sehr viel mehr Daten nehmen und das müssen wir jetzt alles verstehen
und hinkriegen, wenn möglich so schnell wie möglich.
Denn natürlich der LRC läuft und produziert Daten, die wir jetzt noch nicht
richtig bearbeiten können, weil noch nicht alles zusammenpasst.
Und was uns jetzt am meisten beschäftigt ist das, dass wir diesen zweiten Detektor zum Laufen bringen.
Und wenn das dann gemacht ist, dann werden wir eine Kollisionsrate von Faktor
5 höher haben als das, was wir früher hatten. Das ist vielleicht auch noch ein kleiner Unterschied.
Es ist ähnlich wie bei ALICE, wir haben nicht die gleiche Kollisionsrate wie
ATLAS und CMS, wir schieben die einen Strahl vom LHC ein bisschen weg.
Damit sie nicht frontal aufeinander kommen und daher haben wir eine Kollisionsrate,
die leicht ein bisschen niedriger ist.
Wenn wir die gleichen hätten als Atlas und CMS, dann würden wir uns in unserem
Detektor überhaupt nichts mehr sehen.
Elektronisches Signal wäre dann völlig schwarz, überall wäre etwas.
Also wir müssen das ein bisschen so, ja. Too much.
Also wenn die anderen gar nicht genug kriegen können.
Ja genau, bei uns versuchen wir zu optimieren und wir wollen das jetzt optimal
ein bisschen hochschrauben, damit wir mehr Daten bekommen und in unseren Messungen
immer genauer an Standardmodelle rankommen.
Alright, dann würde ich sagen, machen wir mal den Deckel drauf.
Patrick, vielen vielen Dank für die Ausführungen.
Und ja, damit schließe ich hier auch meine Runde ab beim Zernen und hoffe hier
Einblicke gegeben zu haben in die komplexe,
aber auch abenteuerliche Exploration unserer Grundlagen und der Forschung,
die bis weit ins All hinein reicht.
Weil das ist halt so, das was mich auch so ein bisschen motiviert hat.
Raumzeit hat ja so ein bisschen mit der Kosmonologie bisher ein bisschen gespielt,
sagen wir es mal so, weil es ging viel um die Raumfahrt und die Ziele,
aber letzten Endes geht es ja um das gleiche.
Es geht ja um das Erstreben sozusagen zu erklären, was wir eigentlich sehen,
was wir wahrnehmen und vielleicht auch eben das, was wir nicht sehen.
Wie dunkle Materie. Aber einfach irgendwie um Erklärungsmodelle zu machen,
um dann einfach immer wieder an so einem bestimmten Punkt so einen Sprung machen zu können.
Und ich denke, das charakterisiert ja die wissenschaftliche Entwicklung der
letzten 100 Jahre extrem stark. Man hat ja immer wieder so Phasen,
wo man das Gefühl hat, es passiert irgendwie gar nichts. Alle sammeln irgendwie
Daten, was macht ihr denn da eigentlich?
Und dann gibt es immer wieder so einen Punkt, wo dann so, ah ja,
jetzt passt auch irgendwie alles zusammen.
Und das kann ja jederzeit passieren. Also es kann irgendwie morgen soweit sein,
dass wieder irgend so ein Durchbruch verkündet wird. und dann ergeben auch alle
anderen Experimente vielleicht wieder ganz anderen Sinn.
Alright, ich sag nochmal danke, danke fürs Zuhören. Das war's jetzt von mir, vom CERN.
Demnächst geht's dann wieder weiter mit anderen Sachen.
Tschüss und bis bald.